من رام الله ارحب بالكاتب الصحفي والمختص
في الشان الاسرائيلي ايهاب جبارين اهلا بك
معنا سيد ايهاب على ماذا يناور
نتنياهو في كل في ظل هذه المؤشرات
والتطورات التي لمستها للعمليه
العسكريه نعم تحياتي استاذه غنوه وصباح
الخير بدون ان نشك ربما الامر الذي يمكننا
ان نفهم منه على ماذا يناور تحديدا هو
اللافته التي واجهتها اليوم في اتجاه الى
هنا كان مكتوب فيها بجملتين نقوي الجيش
ونتخلى عن بنيامين نتنياهو هو يعلم جيدا
ان هذه هي الاشكاليه وهذا هو المطب
الموجود في الشارع الاسرائيلي في هذه
الاثناء الشارع الاسرائيلي بحاجه لدعم
مطلق لهذا الجيش يدعم الجيش بكل معنى
الكلمه لانه في نهايه المطاف يجب ان نتذكر
ان كل الجمهور الاسرائيلي هو خريج هذه
المؤسسه فب نهايه المطاف لا يستطيع ان
يطعم بها ولا يطعن بتحركاته ولكن
الاشكاليه هي سياسات السياسات التي تتخذ
من وراء الكواليس ليس في الميدان اي
بكلمات اخرى هنالك دعم مطلق في الميدان
الاشكاليه هي في السياسات واشكاليه اتخاذ
السياسات هو يعلم جيدا انه يملك حكومه
64 عضو كنيست ال 64 عضو كنيست المشترك
بينهم ان جلهم من اليمين المتطرف وبالتالي
هذا هي النغمه التي كان يتغنى بها بنيامين
نتنياهو هو يعلم امر واحد في الواقع
الاسرائيلي حكومات اسرائيل تنتحر ولا تقتل
اي بكلمات اخرى لكي تذهب اسرائيل الى
انتخابات او يكون هنالك اي تكتيك يؤدي بها
الى ذلك الانتخابات في ظل كل هذه التحركات
والتركيبات الحاليه هي هو بحاجه لكي يكون
هنالك تمرد من داخل هذه الحكومه هو يعمل
بكل جهده الا يكون هنالك ايه حاله تمرد
يعطي كل ما يريده هذا اليمين وبالتالي
سياسيا هو مرتاح وعلى هذا هو تحديدا هو
يغامر لانه
تحرر هو يرهن على اليمين المتطرف
لاستمراريتها
بدون ان نشاك حتى في داخل الليكود ربما
هنالك امتعضت معينه من نهجه ومن اساليبه
ومن خطابه وحتى كان هنالك بالاسابيع
الاولى تقريبا الاسبوع الثالث والرابع
حديث عن تمرد في داخل هذا الحسر الحزب ضد
بنيامين نتنياهو ولكن في نهايه المطاف اذا
لاحظنا النغمه التي كان يتغنى بها بنيامين
نتنياهو في ظل كل هذه الفتره هي نغمه يعني
يمينيه او صهيونيه دينيه التي تلاقى يعني
تلقى اذانا صاغيه لدى
ال المستوطنين وجمهور المستوطنين وهذه
دلاله واضحه انه بات اكثر منعزلا في في
داخل حزبه وفي اركان حزبه وربما كذلك نقطه
مهمه جدا يجب ان نشير اليها في كل مره يجد
بنيامين نتنياهو نفسه ايه ايه في مازق
شخصي هو يكون اكثر يمينيه اكثر تطرفا يجب
ان نتذكر هو ذات بنيامين نتنياهو الذي في
حكومته الاولى ما بين 96 حتى 9 جلس مع
الراحل ياسر عرفات وكذلك تخلى عن اجزاء في
داخل الخليل يعني من هذا من هذا التطرف
الى التطرف الاخر في داخل اقصى المشهد
اليميني سيدي ايهاب ننتقل الى ملف
المحتجزين ما الذي يحاول ان يبرره نتنياهو
عن عندما يقول ان الضغط العسكري ضروره من
اجل تحرير واخراج المحتجزين في قطاع
غزه يعني ربما حتى على لسان الناطق بلسان
الجيش كان هنالك نوع من يمكن القول خطوه
واحده الى الوراء في كل هذا الخطاب وبدا
يقول بان هنالك عمليات معقده واكثر تركيبا
مما كنا نتوقع
وان ممكن ان نشهد الكثير من الثمن ازاء
هذه العمليه الوحيد الذي ما زال يتغنى في
هذا الخطاب بذات الخطاب خطاب الذي بدا به
منذ اليوم الاول هو بنيامين نتنياهو يعني
حتى جالانت و جانس كان لديهم خطاب نوعا ما
مغير بنيامين نتنياهو يعلم جيدا في في ظل
كل هذه الاثناء ان لا ملاذ له اخر من الا
من استمراريه هذه الحرب يجب ان نتذكر هو
اشغل الشارع الاسرائيلي على مدى خمس سنوات
في ازمه قياض الان هو يريد ان يشغله في
ازمه امنيه لذات الاسباب ولذات الاهداف في
نهايه المطاف لكي يلوذ بنفسه من الفار
انذاك من تعديلات القضائيه او عفوا من
الملفات القضائيه والان من الملفات التي
تنظره في اللجان التحقيق في السابع من
اكتوبر فبالتالي هذه هي التركيبه التي
تحرك بنيامين نتنياهو مالن شخصيه ولا
اعتقد انه في كل تاريخ اسرائيل واجه مثل
هذه الازمه القياديه بالذات في ظل ازمه
امنيه حرجه كالتي تواجهها اليوم واضح جدا
ان عندما اعلن بنيامين نتنياهو عن داف
هذه الحرب وهذا العدوان كان لدي هدفين
اثنين الهدف الاول اماطى بحماس والهدف
الثاني اعاده الاسرى
النتيجه حماس ما زالت موجوده وهو بالتالي
يميط ويقتل المدنيين في داخل القطاع وكذلك
يقتل اسراه اي يعني حتى اهداف الحرب التي
اعلنها المردود الذي يتلقاه الشارع
الاسرائيلي والراي العام العالمي
بالمناسبه هو مردود عكسي لهذه الاهداف
ولهذا السبب يمكن القول هو خسر الراي
العام العالمي خسر ال الدعم العالمي الذي
كان يتلقاه في الاسابيع الاولى والان
المراهنه الحقيقيه هي على الشارع
الاسرائيلي ولكي نفهم ذلك بشكل مطلق وبشكل
اكبر بدا هنالك يعني بكلمات فعليه نوع من
الشرخ ذات الشرخ الذي شهدته اسرائيل في
على مدى الاشهر السابقه نتنياهو يحاول ان
ينسخه الان بنسخه جديده في كل ما يتعلق
ملفات الاسر يوم امس امهات جنود موجودون
في
داخل القطاع كانت لديهم نوع من المض
مظاهرات امام الكرياه في ذات المكان الذي
يحتج فيه ذوي الم الاسرى عفوا كانت لديهم
كذلك هنالك وقفه احتجاجيه تطالب بمسح غزه
اباده غزه هو يحاول ان ينقل هذا الشرخ
ويراهن على هذا الشرخ في داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي لكي يلقى دعما اكثر
لسياساته وا ترجمتها على المدى العسكري
لكن بطبيعه الحال يجب ان نتذكر نقطه مهمه
جدا هذا الشخ مهمه جدا هي التسريبات
التسريبات التسريبات التي نسمعها في
الايام الاخيره من داخل الجيش انا
باعتقادي هي ليست بريئه الجيش مربك في كل
ما يواجهه في داخل الميدان يجب ان نتذكر
ان هنالك الكثير من الضغينه من رئاسه هيئه
الاركان ومن قاض الجيش على مدى الاشهر
السابقه في كل ما واجهه من ازمه وشرق
حقيقي بسلاح الجو وسلاح الاحتياط وكذلك
الان هنالك ازمه
وضغينة ليفي وبنيامين نتنياهو كانت
ترجمتها في في عده محاور في الكابينت
وباعتقادي الجيش يحاول تسريب مثل كل هذه
المشاهد من حاله الارباك ومن حاله الخساره
لكي يحاول ان يؤجج الشارع الاسرائيلي اكثر
فاكثر ضد شيمين نت ي مدى انت تلحظ ان هناك
شرخا بين صنع القرار لدى القياده العسكريه
ولدى حكومه نتنياهو
سؤال جميل جدا يعني يجب ان نتذكر ان في
داخل الكابينت الحكومه هي مجرد جزء من هذا
الكابينت في نهايه المطاف نحن نتحرك نتحدث
عن التركيبه الامنيه الاستخباراتيه
والعسكريه وكذلك اجزاء من المعارضه يعني
جانس وايزن كوت في نهايه المطاف هم مسميات
معارضه وليس مسميات ائتلاف في داخل هذه
الحكومه وان كانوا جزءا منها وبالتالي وفق
هذه التركيبه ووفق هذه التعقيدات نحن
نتحدث عن نتنياهو رب ربما الدبلوماسي وهذا
ربما هذه النقطه الوحيده التي تحتسب اليه
امام اجزاء عسكريه امنيه في المقابل في
داخل الكابينيت وهذه هي التركيبه المعقده
انا باعتقادي كلهم لهم الكثير من الضغينه
الدوله العميقه بالمناسبه هي هي التي
تتحدى بنيامين نتنياهو هو يعلم جيدا انه
يمسك ال الخلطه السياسيه والخلطه
الانتخابيه بقبضه بقبضه محكمه وعلى هذا هو
يراهن وفي المقابل يجب ان نتذكر ان مثل
هذه التسريبات في نهايه المطاف مثل هذه
الشرخ في داخل الشارع وعدم الثقه في
القرارات السياسيه هي التي ممكن ان تؤدي
اكثر فاكثر على انشقاقات في داخل المشهد
السياسي من ليس لا نقول اقصى اليمين ولكن
اليمين الذي السوي لنقول ذلك بكلمات
معتدله وعلى هذا تراهن باقي الاركان
الملاحظه مهمه جدا ان في ظل كل ما يصرح به
بنيامين نتنياهو دادي برنيا يقوم ببحث
المفاوضات مع الوسطاء القطريين والمصريين
كذلك بطبيعه الحال الحديث عن الكثير من
التسهيلات في داخل الضفه الغربيه
التسهيلات الماليه بدات تطفو الى سطح ففي
ظل كل هذا نعم يعني هو ليس سيد المشهد
لوحده يجب ان نتذكر وربما حتى يجب ان
نقولها ان اسرائيل نوعا ما بهذه
الاعتبارات في داخل الكابينيت اكبر من
مجرد قرار لبنيامين نتنياهو ان كان هو
يتصدر المشهد حاليا شكرا لك من رام الله
الكاتب الصحفي والمختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي ايهاب جبارين